[Music]
hello good morning everyone welcome to
improving battery life with restrictions
my name is tingu I'm a developer
advocate from the partner dev'reaux team
hi I'm Amit I'm a software engineer on
the android framework team so today we
want to start with this notification
that we've all received hopefully never
around this time of the day knowing that
our battery is running out can be really
frustrating and sometimes scary
depending on where we are and what we're
doing at that time these days we rely so
much on our devices for navigation I'm
talking to our friends and family taking
pictures and even translate for us when
we're traveling in a foreign country but
all these cool features and amazing apps
that you build cannot help the user if
their battery is dead so that's why
today we're talking about how we're
gonna improve battery with your help
hopefully and this is what we are going
to cover first we'll talk about what's
consuming power and how we measure power
consumption and then we're going to go
through powers the power saving features
were introduced in recent years and in
the end we're going to talk about how
your app will be affected by these
restrictions and what you can do to work
with them next I'll pass it over to a
myth to talk about what's consuming
power I quickly walked through how we
actually estimate how an app consumes
power how much power it's consuming on
the device these are the typical
components our hardware components that
are consuming power on a typical phone
I've highlighted some of the top
consumers you got an earful about
display and how much power that consumes
from Chris and Alan running the CPU at
high frequencies is also pretty
expensive and it's transferring data
over the cell network is quite expensive
as well so
when each device is manufactured the OEM
provides something called a power
profile what the power profile contains
is the average current drawn by various
subsystems that we want to measure in
real time and for example you know if
you turn the screen on at minimum
brightness it might be about 100
milliamps and if you crank it up to full
brightness depending on the technology
let's say it adds another 300 milliamps
so we keep track of that in real time
CPU at different frequencies has
different power consumption so here that
in the power profile as well at runtime
what we do is that there's a subsystem
called battery stats it tracks what each
app is doing it measures how long it's
consuming each of these resources like
how much CPU time at what frequency how
many data packets it's transferring and
so on we take those values and then we
multiply with the power cost for each of
those in the power profile and we get an
approximate estimate of how much how
many milliamp hours the particular app
has drained and then we rank all the
different apps based on their
consumption presented to the user so
they can see that in settings and then
they can learn for themselves what's
really draining their battery so let's
talk about how the OS is trying to help
the user extend their battery life but
first broadly speaking there are two
reasons why an app runs right the users
launching it it's running in the
foreground users actively using the app
now that's as developers that's
something you don't want them to not do
but that's a whole different topic about
digital well being and trying to you
know help users control how much time
they spend on apps but one note I want
to leave about that here because we're
not going to talk too much about it is
there is a concept about suspending apps
and that's something you might want to
read about and how that impacts your app
if the user suspends the app for say the
rest of the day but we'll focus on how
we try to limit background activity from
an app
a napkin scheduled background work by
you know using jobs or alarms or setting
up a background service it can also
register for callbacks for external
triggers such as a push message or you
walking past a geofence
so over the years we've introduced
several features in the OS to save
battery first in marshmallow introduced
doze or deep toes as the name suggests
it puts the device into a really deep
sleep under the condition that the
device is not moving so let's say you
left it on your desk or on your
nightstand you forgot to plug it in it
basically shuts down a lot of the
background activity so that you you can
really extend your battery life but this
is not really how we use our daily
phones right we are walking around with
it we're using it throughout the day so
we came up with those on-the-go or light
doze what that does is it puts the
device into a slightly lighter sleep and
wakes up more frequently so that it has
an opportunity to see if there is any
pending work to do so that your data is
reasonably fresh but it's not in front
of you you're not using the screen so it
can shut down some of the background
work you're probably all familiar with
the Oreo restrictions on background
services as well as limiting the number
of implicit broadcasts that you can wake
up to and as of this month everyone
needs to target Android Oreo or above
because otherwise you can publish to the
Play Store but we'll focus more on
what's new and P adaptive battery app
restrictions or background restrictions
and we've also made some improvements to
battery saver adaptive battery is
actually an evolution of app standby
that was introduced back in marshmallow
along with those what app standby did
was put apps into two state two possible
States active or inactive based on usage
adaptive battery extends this into four
buckets now where active is the least
restrictive and based on usage we move
it into some of the other buckets and
rare is the most restrictive
for instance if you were Google i/o and
you install the i/o app by now it should
have gone to the rare bucket because you
haven't been using it so how does the OS
assign these buckets to each app it
starts off when you are installing the
app in an ever bucket it's not shown
here it's really not that relevant but
once you launch the app or every time
you launch the app or any kind of strong
interaction like clicking on a
notification from the app the app goes
into the active bucket and it stays
there for awhile and maybe in a few
hours it comes down to the working set
where it starts applying restrictions on
what you can do in the background and
then a little later
most of frequent and then to rare and
then we uninstall your app I'm just
kidding we don't do that and if there's
some kind of an indirect interaction
such as you're looking at a notification
by pulling down the shade it's not a
clear indication that it's an active
usage of the app so we put it in a
slightly restricted straight which is
the working set what is actually
adaptive about this is if the device
happens to have a machine learning
algorithm what it does is it watches
your usage patterns learns over time and
then it decides okay this app is
probably going to be used in the next
couple of hours let me put it in the
active set and maybe it can freshen up
its data maybe it needs to download the
latest news or whatever and once it
feels that maybe the app is not going to
be used for a while it might move it
into one of the lower buckets so this
actually really improves our ability to
reduce the amount of work that apps do
on the background and it's not your
fault
it's just you don't know how the users
when the users gonna launch you so we're
trying to help with that app
restrictions is another feature which is
kind of an extreme version of background
limits we really limit what the app can
do in the background so it's mostly
meant for apps that you just want to be
doing work in the foreground right there
are two ways the app can go into this
state the user might see in settings
that your app is draining battery and
decides to manually restrict the app the
other way is the
system is monitoring certain criteria
about how the app is behaving and if it
feels that it's doing anything excessive
over certain thresholds that we said it
suggests to the user hey do you want to
restrict this app because it is draining
your battery in the background these are
things that we will improve over time
the kind of criteria and the thresholds
and OMS are also free to add their own
criteria so what is restricted if
phenomen is a background restricted the
usual jobs alarms foreground services
you can't run a foreground service if
your app is in the restricted state
because as far as the user is concerned
it is still kind of a background thing
if you see something happening in the
notification and it's doing work in the
background FCM as of January will be
restricted as well so you won't get any
measured messages when your app is in
the restricted state you also don't get
location updates and one thing that's
unique about app restrictions is even
while the device is charging we don't
let you run in the background this is
not true for any of the other
restrictions and the reason is this is
not just about saving battery it's also
about annoyances and maybe privacy
concerns battery saver was improved and
PI as well it's very similar to how a
predictions work but it applies it
across all the apps some of the
differences are foreground services are
okay to run while in battery saver
because you might want to be listening
to music while on battery saber there
are no restrictions on push messages
network is restricted jobs and alarms
the usual ones and one thing that's new
in PI is we turn off location services
completely at least on pixel devices OMS
might not choose to do that so we have
some api's that you can use to detect
which state you're in
which restricted state for example you
can ask you should stars what is your
current standby bucket at this moment
but if you want to debug something or
want to know how frequently you are in
some rare bucket you can also get
historical information about your
standby bucket changes you can also
check if your background
six right now and you might maybe you
want to tell the user something about
that or maybe your critical services
will not work but please don't nag the
user if they don't want you to run they
don't want you to run and you can also
check if battery saver is on internally
it's called power saver mode hand it
back to Jing you think you a myth so how
is there a perfected so anytime to the
system your app will be in one of these
two states it will be either in the
foreground or the background and
whenever your app is considered to be in
foreground all these restrictions are
lifted so you can run whenever you need
to but when you're a basing background
and the device is not charging all of
the battery saver features that miss
just talked about any of them could be
enabled which means that your jobs
alarms network access and fcm messages
could be restricted and next we have
some really beautiful diagrams which
will show you how they are affected
first let's look at the scheduled jobs
given that all constraints you have on
the job is satisfied these are the
features which will affect when this job
will get run first let's look at the
device level if the device is in DOS
then your job will be deferred to
maintenance window and then if user
decide to turn on battery saver or off
restrictions meaning restrict your app
from the battery setting your job will
be deferred until user opens the app or
when the app is in foreground and none
of those are true then it's up to apps
done by bucket or adaptive battery in
pixel your job could be deferred up to
24 hours that's when your app belongs to
the rear bucket and that's the worst
case which means that even in the worst
case your job was to get run every day
so similarly for alarm manager alarms
these features will affect when your
alarms fare fire
when devices ink toast your alarm will
be deferred to maintenance window and if
the user turn on battery saver or they
restrict your app your alarm will be
deferred when until your app is in
foreground and I'll finally to the app
standby bucket your your alarm could be
delayed unto you up to two hours if your
app belongs to that rare budget so if
your use case really requires that exact
time execution then for example like if
you want to remind it user they need to
take medicine or a TV program that they
subscribe to is about to start so for
these use cases you can use this site
well idle method that we provided so
your alarm will fire on time but we
never use when you're here when you are
using alarm manager to wake up the
device frequently and imagine that if
every app is doing that at a different
time then you are draining a lot of
battery that's why we have the excessive
wake up on your end or vitals page so if
you see your excessive wake up on vital
stage is caused by alarm a nature I
would highly recommend that you think
about maybe it's time for you to migrate
to some other api's like job scheduler
if you're sending push notifications you
are probably already using firebase
cloud messaging and similarly your FCM
messages will also be affected when the
device is in tow your normal priority
messages will be deferred to the
maintenance window which means that if
you're sending high priority message
that message will be delivered
immediately this is because high party
FCM message they are created to trigger
action that's visible to the user like
sending a notification so user can act
on it
and if the user turn on battery saver
then still your messages will be
delivered as it is as a miss mentioned
earlier if the user restricted your app
currently the messages are still
delivered but as of January next year
2019 all these messages will be
discarded because this is a strong
signal from the user that they want to
restrict the app and finally in the app
standby bucket there's a different cap
on each bucket that your app could
belong to the more active the bucket is
the more high party message you can send
but if you reach that coda don't worry
we're not discarding your message which
is done waiting them to normal party
which means that they could be delayed a
little bit
when devices in DOS so if you really
want to reach your user with that
important message don't use high
priority for operations that don't
require user interaction whenever you
are sending high priority it should
trigger a notification or something user
can interact with okay here's the
summary of the power saving features
that we talked today one thing to note
is that all of these features we see
here they will apply on any app that's
running on Android I device no matter
which target SDK you are targeting
so our first advice to you is please
test your app against all of these
features we have a DP command on the
developer dock you can use to put your
app in all of these features and test
your use cases to see if your push
notifications are coming through if your
job is running are you handling that
case well the good news is except for
the high party of see a message
restriction that I just mentioned all
actually none of the other restrictions
is new we had them since those so if
your app works well under dos there is
very much it's very likely that you
don't need to change much to work with
these features our second advice to you
is whenever you're running tasks in the
background please keep in mind to use
this lazy first design principle try to
reduce the work you're running in the
background think about do I really need
to run in the background in this wait to
man a basing foreground and think about
do I need to run with this frequency
maybe reduce some
I'm doing in the background and if you
really need to run in the background try
to defer that work to a later time say
when device is plugged in or think about
that exact lerm does it have to happen
at that exact time can it wait and
finally try to coalesce the work you do
in the background so in lollipop we
introduce job scheduler which is the
wait for you to help the system to
intelligently batch all the background
work and this year we'll introduce the
work manager in jetpack which makes
running background work easier and since
when it hits stable it will be the
recommended way to do background work so
we're starting mind let's look at this
upgraded view of how you do things in
the background if you are running a work
if you need to execute a work or do a
sync
that's deferrable locally then work
manager is your answer if this work is
triggered online then you would use a
FCM message with work manager meaning
you would want to use FCM message to
notify your app that there's some work
you need to do or you need to sync with
the app server and then in the message
handler you include that work if you use
a case doesn't work fit with either of
these cases and you need to run
something at that Excel time then you
would want to use alarm manager finally
if this is something that the user
started user is aware that it's running
and it must happen immediately right now
then you would use foreground service
but please whenever you're using this
foreground service ad that action in the
notification because there's nothing
more frustrating than seeing a bunch of
notifications but there's nothing I can
do about them because focal service
notification you cannot dismiss them so
please add that action in a notification
for user to stop their service and then
notification is dismissed and if you
reach the end I would say go back to the
top or you should wait until your app is
in foreground
we have a will commander talk later
today at 1:00 p.m. please go to that to
learn how you can use work manager to do
a background work and we also have a lot
of best practices and guidance how you
can help us to help users save battery
in this PowerBlock series please visit
to learn more and we will be in the
office over this afternoon for any
questions thank you
[Music]